- [Narrator] Named for its method
of burying rotting
carcasses to feed its young,
this is the grave digger
of the animal kingdom,
the American burying beetle.
(intriguing music)
These beetles feed on
small decomposing animals
like birds and mice.
Inside their antennae are
strong chemical receptors
that detect rotting meat.
They have powerful wings and
will travel long distances
to reach their meal.
Males and females work
together to bury the corpse,
and females will then lay her eggs nearby.
After the larvae hatch, both
parents tend to their young,
a behavior rarely found in insects.
Once a prolific beetle
found in over 35 states
across the U.S., today it
can be found in just six.
Listed as endangered back in 1989,
the American burying
beetle's future is bleak.
While conservation efforts are underway,
there is still a long way to go.
This is the American burying beetle.